merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de la transition écologique les
la récente publication des chiffres de
la construction neuve pour 2022 confirme
ce que nous n'avons cessé de dire depuis
plusieurs mois plusieurs ici au
gouvernement la situation n'est pas
dramatique elle est catastrophique
rarement on a connu des chiffres aussi
dramatiques moins 25% pour les
promoteurs privés - 30% pour les
constructions individuelles 350
000 unités prévues en 2023 pour mémoire
après le plan de relance de Jean-Louis
Borloo on était à
486040% de moins annoncé pour l'année
qui vient et ça va continuer des
faillites en cascade sont annoncés dans
la promotion pour le logement social la
réforme Funès des aPL de la loi Elan a
assécher les finances des offices HLM et
on est pour la troisième année
consécutive en dessous des 100 000
logements sociaux
sans parler des mesures que vous avez
prises sur un certain nombre de sujets
par exemple 0 artificialisation net
heureusement que le Sénat est en train
de les corriger donc monsieur le
ministre ma question est simple est-ce
que vous avez prévu enfin un plan de
relance pour relancer la construction
neuve dans notre pays comme nous l'avons
fait avec succès sous Nicolas Sarkozy
Jacques Chirac qu'est-ce que vous avez
prévu des mesures fiscales de relance
exceptionnelle comme nous avons réussi à
le faire sous le gouvernement de
François Fillon
pour vous répondre la parole des taux
ministres de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
Marc-Philippe de Bresse d'abord quelques
chiffres très récents et qui seront
l'occasion de d'objectiver les choses on
a une augmentation des autorisations
en 2022 qui remonte à un niveau que nous
n'avions pas connu depuis plus de 6 ans
à plus de 480 000 en hausse de 3%. mais
dans le même temps on a une baisse des
mises en chantier de 3% à 376 000 avec
les indications que vous donnez entre
les deux on a des phénomènes structurels
je vais revenir mais on a aussi un
phénomène conjoncturel qui est la très
forte augmentation des refus de prêt
dans un double contexte ou globalement
les taux d'intérêt sont passés de 1,5 à
3-20 sur 20 ans et ou dans le même temps
le coût moyen de la construction a
augmenté avec un effet d'inflation
généralisé en 2022 particulièrement vrai
dans le champ du logement premier sujet
à côté de ça par rapport à cette
question des prêts et de la baisse de la
demande puisque nous avons eu 39% de
baisse de la demande au dernier
trimestre et ça c'est pas un sujet
gouvernemental la baisse de la demande
elle est liée à des acheteurs qui
cessent d'acheter pas à une absence
d'offre
la réforme du taux d'usure en faisant en
sorte de la mensualiser depuis le
premier février pour fluidifier une
partie du marché le premier élément de
réponse les réponses plus structurelles
elles seront prises dans la continuité
du CNR logement qui se termine au mois
d'avril nous discutons en ce moment avec
tous les professionnels vous en avez
cité un certain nombre il y en a
d'autres et dans ces autres il y a les
élus l'ambition du président de la
République c'est d'ouvrir le chantier de
la décentralisation du logement vous
connaissez parfaitement ces questions
vous les avez connu comme éduc local
vous les avez connus comme membres du
gouvernement on a eu l'habitude de
réfléchir sur un combien là où la
disparité des situations fait que c'est
le ou et le comment qui mérite d'être
questionné et la décentralisation du
logement elle est au cœur d'une ambition
y compris sur la rénovation énergétique
dans un dialogue franc avec les communes
avec les intercommunalités et avec les
départements changements des zonage des
centralisation des dispositifs soutient
aux maires bâtisseurs ce sont ces
ensembles sur lesquels nous travaillons
monsieur dobresse
monsieur le ministre vous l'avez dit
j'ai été en son temps mini du logement
il faut que vous révisiez vos chiffres
les notaires viennent de sortir le
dernier chiffre pour le dernier
trimestre 2022 par rapport à un an c'est
moins 25% les permis de construire
monsieur le ministre moi 25% annoncé je
vais prendre un seul chiffre si vous
rapportez le nombre de constructions
neuves à la population nombre de ménages
français c'est le plus bas chiffres que
nous allons connaître depuis 1951 ça
avait donné l'appel de l'abbé Pierre
monsieur le ministre vous sous-estimer
le problème parce que vous êtes
confronté à des objectifs stratégiques
contradictoires il est grand temps que
le gouvernement se réveille
[Applaudissements]